Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass in der 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Da läuft es langsam auf ein spannendes Saisonfinale hinaus. Deshalb wollen wir uns heute damit beschäftigen, hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 252. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr hier den Rasenfunk Kurzpass eingeschaltet habt. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die 2. Männer Bundesliga. Das dürfte euch nicht mehr überraschen, wenn ihr das Intro aufmerksam gehört habt. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Auch das sollte euch nicht mehr so komplett vom Stuhl werfen. Aber unsere Besetzung wird euch wirklich aus dem Nichts erwischen. Denn wir haben heute wieder fantastische Gäste. Ich freue mich sehr, hier eine bekannte Stimme aus der deutschen Podcastlandschaft zu begrüßen. Tim Ecksteen ist hier vom Millan-Ton bei Twitter, auch der Tim-Ecksteen. Also denkbar einfach zu finden. Hallo Tim. Ja, schön, dass du hier bist. Schön mal zu so einem, also es ist ein günstiger Moment, würde ich sagen, dass wir miteinander sprechen. Günstiger als das letzte Mal.
Also auf jeden Fall. Ja, die letzten beiden Male war es nicht ganz so günstig. Das muss ich schon mal sagen.
Ja, ich will auch heute auf jeden Fall wissen, was da passiert ist, ob wir jetzt auch gegen Dreierketten-Teams spielen können. Das habe ich mir vom letzten Mal noch gemerkt. Das ist das große Problem. Also darüber wollen wir sprechen und wir wollen auch sprechen über den SSV Jahn Regensburg. Und da begrüße ich hier Robert Fischer von 1889 FM. Hallo Robert. Auch für dich kein schlechter Zeitpunkt. Ich muss sagen, ihr habt es alle ganz gut erwischt.
Ja, vielleicht war das auch dein Auswahlkriterium.
Ja, ich bin ein Erfolgsfan. Ich lade mir nur erfolgreiche Teams ein. Das weiß man ja. Nee, war es nicht. Aber ich dachte, Regensburg wurde immer so ein bisschen – ja, wie soll ich das sagen? Also, ich meine, du hast es ja vielleicht auch gehört. Alle oder viele Gäste hatten eine Meinung zu Regensburg, aber die war dann immer dann doch relativ generell. Und ja, naja, dann steigen sie halt vielleicht ab und so weiter. Das war eher so der Grund, dass ich mir dachte, naja, da müssen wir jetzt schon mal ein bisschen tiefer reingehen, als immer nur so allgemein über Regensburg zu sprechen. Das war der Grund, dass du hier bist. Also schön, dass du da bist. Und dann freue ich mich unheimlich, dass wir hier Petra Neher haben. Die kennt ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn ihr im Forum aktiv seid auch schon, denn da ist sie nämlich auch sehr aktiv. Auf Twitter ist sie die Frau unter Strich Neher und sie ist der mir bekannteste, wollte ich eigentlich sagen, der einzige mir bekannte, erst FC Heidenheim-Fan, über den wir heute auch sprechen werden. Petra, wie schön, dass du hier bist.
Hallo Max, vielen Dank für die mutige Einladung. Und ja, du kannst es zugeben, ich bin die Einzige, die du kennst.
Ja, ich habe noch kurz überlegt, ob das irgendwie doof ist, aber es ist halt leider wirklich so. Es war nie so ganz einfach, Heidenheim-Fans zu finden. Deswegen schön, dass du hier bist und du hast ja schon im Forum durch lange, lange Beiträge schon deine Expertise bewiesen. Und jetzt freue ich mich sehr, dass wir das endlich mal in den Podcast reinheben, damit alle auch was davon haben. Also schön, dass du hier bist. Bevor wir losliegen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, noch der obligatorische Hinweis. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung und bezahlen davon auch unseren Gästen ein Honorar unter rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Könnt ihr erfahren, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Bitte tut es, damit es den Rasenfunk noch lange gibt und wir viele Sendungen machen können. Jetzt gehen wir rein. Wir schauen uns die Tabelle an nach 25 gespielten Spielen. Da thront über allem Darmstadt 98 mit 52 Punkten. Aber schon auf Platz 2, Petra, kommt der 1. FC Heidenheim mit 50 Punkten. Erst 3 Niederlagen, sage und schreibe, 51 erzielten Toren. Also einer sehr, sehr guten Bilanz. Und bis zur letzten Niederlage muss man, glaube ich, auch schon ein ganz schönes Stück zurückgehen. Es ist schon so weit, dass ich es hier in der Vorschau der letzten 6 Spiele gar nicht mehr sehe. Kann es sein, dass ihr dieses Jahr aufsteigt, Petra?
Davon gehe ich aus. Also wenn wir dieses Jahr nicht aufsteigen, dann werden es harte Jahre fürchtig. So nah dran war Heidenheim noch nie. Und ich bin sehr zuversichtlich, dass es funktionieren wird. Ja, tatsächlich.
Das sind mal sehr selbstbewusst zu tun, aber man kann es sehr leicht erklären. Also ich habe es jetzt kurz nachgeguckt. Letzte Niederlage bei Braunschweig am 19. Spieltag. Und dann muss man schon irgendwie bis in den Oktober hineingehen, bis da mal verloren wurde. Was ist es denn bei Heidenheim, was jetzt diese Saison unterscheidet von den letzten? Sind es nur die Ergebnisse oder steckt da noch mehr dahinter?
Da steckt eine ganze Menge mehr dahinter. Vor allem ist es die Konstanz. Also es gab schon jede Saison eine sehr gute Phase. Es gab aber auch jede Saison eine relativ schlechte Phase. Und so konstant wie in dieser Saison, kann ich mich tatsächlich nicht erinnern, dass es mal so perfekt gelaufen ist. Man hat zwar auf acht angefangen nach dem ersten Spiel, aber dann ging es nie mehr weiter runter als bis zu Platz fünf. Und das war so tatsächlich noch nie da.
Und womit hängt das zusammen? Ist das jetzt – ich weiß jetzt gar nicht. Hat jetzt irgendwie Frank Schmidt in Jahrnummer – ist es 17 oder wie lange er schon da ist?
Ich glaube, das Einzige, was sich in den letzten 16 Jahren nie verändert hat, dann war es Frank Schmidt und seine Herangehensweise an den Fußball. Der Kader ist mittlerweile, würde ich sagen, ein wirklich breiter Kader geworden. Es gab immer schon so ein paar Spitzenspieler und danach wurde es etwas dünn. Vor allem, wenn dann gleichzeitig zwei, drei Spieler ausgefallen sind, dann war es ganz schwer, das auszufüllen. Mittlerweile gibt es aber einige, die qualitativ einfach überhaupt nicht abfallen. Wenn du in die Topspieler-Listen guckst, dann tummeln sich zwar nicht unbedingt viele ganz vorne, aber eben sehr viele in der Mitte. Das hilft sehr. Dann ist es natürlich immer ein Team Kleindienst. Ich glaube, dass jede Mannschaft, in der ein Team Kleindienst so funktioniert, wie er bei uns funktioniert, fast gar keine Chance hat, nicht erfolgreich zu sein. Und immerhin hat Frank Schmidt was geschafft, was Christian Streich nicht geschafft hat, nämlich, dass Team Kleindienst funktioniert.
Ja, Shots fired. Ich nehme das zur Kenntnis. Aber das kann man ja auch bei 19 Toren und vier Vorlagen in 23 Spielen. Also, Tim Kleindienst thront über allen, hatte ja auch dieses Wahnsinnsspiel. Mit wie viel Treffer waren es? Vier oder fünf? Ich kriege es gerade gar nicht mehr genau zusammen. Das war noch gar nicht so lange her. Wie wird er denn eingebunden? Früher war es ja viel über Flanken bei Heidenheim. Und Standardsituationen haben auch immer eine große Rolle gespielt. Ist es jetzt auch so in dieser Saison?
Ja, aber nicht nur. Also vor allem beim Kleindienst ist es so, Kleindienst ist überall. Also der erholt sich die Bälle auch selber und arbeitet unheimlich viel mit nach hinten. Und Kleindienst hat Florian Pick entdeckt oder Florian Pick hat Tim Kleindienst entdeckt. Und die beiden funktionieren unglaublich gut. Die verstehen sich gut, die verstehen sich auch gut neben Platz und Pick scheint auch wirklich immer zu wissen, wo Kleindienst steht. Und ich glaube, dass ihm das auch gefehlt hat. Und Pick kam ja aus Kaiserslautern, 20 mit Kühlweather zusammen und hat sehr lange gebraucht, bis er einen Heidenheim-Fuß gefasst hat. Und der funktioniert jetzt wunderbar und so funktioniert auch Kleindienst. Dann haben wir natürlich ja Niklas Beste, der Beste, also wenn wir jetzt mal callauen wollen und das ist ein sehr flexibler Offensivspieler, der, glaube ich, die besten Ecken im Moment in der 2. Liga bringt.
Und so fühlt sich das dann also gut zusammen. Ich meine, all diese Namen, die sind auch schon gefallen, bis jetzt auf Florian Pick in den letzten Segmenten, die wir zu Heidenheim hatten. Und gleichzeitig viel auch – ich glaube, Tim, das hast du doch damals sogar referiert – hast du mir nicht die Laufstatistiken von Heidenheim um die Ohren geschlagen, in irgendwie – Kurzpass – irgendwann in der Hinrunde mal?
Ja, habe ich dir. Und das ist auch immer noch so. Der 1. FC Heidenheim ist das Team in der Liga, was am meisten Kilometer läuft, am meisten sprintet, deutlich am meisten sprintet und mit Abstand am meisten intensive Läufe hat. Und Petra, du hast Tim Kleindienst angesprochen. Das ist aus meiner Sicht momentan oder diese Saison auf jeden Fall der beste Spieler der Liga. Und zwar nicht nur, weil er 19 Tore gemacht hat, sondern das finde ich halt auch an dem so besonders. Der hat auch die meisten Zweikämpfe in der ganzen Liga gewonnen und der hat die meisten Kopfballduelle in der ganzen Liga gewonnen mit großem Abstand. Das ist der Spieler, der die meisten intensiven Läufe zieht. Der ist auf Platz 3 bei den Sprints. Und der ist – also Frank Schmidt hat mal nicht umsonst, hat er über Tim Kleindienst gesagt, dass er mein bester Defensivspieler ist, den ich habe, weil er gerade auch im Gegenpressing so gut ist. Aber jetzt in dieser Saison ist er halt auch, was das Toreschießen angeht, enorm gut. Und Toreschießen ist bei Heidenheim ja sowieso ein Thema. Max, du weißt, ich bin ein Fan von den Expected Goals. Und wenn man sich da anschaut, was der 1. FC Heidenheim macht, die ja momentan 51 Treffer geschossen hat, erzielt das beste Angriff der Liga. Die haben einen Expected Goals-Wert von 33, 34 je nach Anbieter. Also sind dann um 17, 18 Tore besser als nach Expected Goals. Das ist eine unfassbare Abschlusseffizienz. Da ist Tim Kleinings natürlich auch ganz vorne dabei, der eine um 10 Tore bessere Abschlusseffizienz hat, wenn man das mit den Expected Goals vergleicht. Also das ist schon enorm. Wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, wie die Tore gegen Karlsruhe gefallen sind, bei dem 5-2 lagen sie 0-2 hin, drehen es auf 5-2, haben Expected Goals-Wert von 0, 9. Das ist alles ein Schuss nach dem anderen, das ist unterhaltbar. Das ist einfach eine unfassbare Effizienz und Qualität. Das ist auf jeden Fall aufstiegswürdig. Das sehe ich auch so.
Sie haben halt eine unheimliche Selbstverständlichkeit entwickelt. Die überrollen dich einfach. Ich glaube, dass vor allem das Spiel gegen den HKSC so ziemlich alles über diese Mannschaft aussagt. Die liegen 0-2 zurück und du hast nicht das Gefühl, dass das irgendwas ausmacht. Die schütteln sich einmal kurz. Du hast auch schon gemerkt, bevor das 2-1 dann gefallen ist, sind die schon wieder ins Laufen und ins Rollen gekommen. Es war eigentlich klar, wo es hingeht. Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen merkwürdig, aber ich war mir sehr sicher, dass sie dieses Spiel noch drehen.
Offensichtlich die Spieler ja auch.
Ja, man sieht es ihnen an. Das ist eine ganz bestimmte Korbosprache, die ihnen Frank Schmidt tatsächlich vermittelt hat, und das ist sein Credo. Das siehst du den Spielern einfach an. Es gibt eigentlich nicht diesen Punkt. Man sieht ja bei vielen Mannschaften, wenn es mal ganz blöd läuft, man hat es auch beim KSC gesehen, dann hängen irgendwann die Schultern. Dann hast du das Gefühl, okay, sie ergeben sich jetzt. Das war es, jetzt wird es ganz schlimm. Das Gefühl hast du bei den Heidenheimern fast nie.
Und gleichzeitig zeigt ja gerade dieser Kleindienstwechsel auch, dass vielleicht noch was anderes in Heidenheim passiert ist. Denn Tim Kleindienst ist ja doppelter Rekordtransfer von Heidenheim. Und zwar einmal zur Saison 1920 und dann eben zur Saison 21, 22. Einmal so rund 3 Millionen, einmal so rund 3, 5 Millionen. Aber die Zahl ist weniger wichtig als der Fakt, dass Heidenheim ansonsten in der Regel eigentlich immer eine positive Transferbilanz hatte oder so leicht im Minus. Aber so sehr ins Risiko ist man tatsächlich jetzt nur für diesen einen Spieler gegangen und das jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal. Steckt dahinter auch die Ambition, es jetzt wirklich mal zu schaffen mit dem Bundesliga-Aufstieg? So ein bisschen wie das bei Union vor ein paar Jahren war, dass die immer noch nach außen hin gesagt haben, na, Aufstieg und so muss nicht sein. Aber intern haben schon viele Leute auch damals schon gesagt, nee, eigentlich müsste das jetzt mal passieren bei dem, was man investiert hat.
Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen merkwürdig, aber das Ziel Erste Liga stammt eigentlich schon aus dem Jahr 1994. Es ist tatsächlich so, da spielte die Mannschaft damals noch als Heidenheimer Sportbund, als HSB in der Landesliga und der Abteilungsleiter damals hieß Holger Sandwald. Und der hat schon in der Landesliga davon gesprochen, dass irgendwann der Tag kommt, an dem er die Heidenheimer in der ersten Bundesliga sieht. Und es wird zwar seit Jahren, es gibt seit Jahren immer dieses öffentliche Understatement von beiden, also sowohl von Frank Schmidt als auch von Holger Sandwald, aber das ist ein öffentliches Understatement. Die wollen beide hoch in die 1. Liga, 100%ig. Und meiner Meinung nach ist das auch seit Jahren akribisch geplant, da hinzukommen. Und was Kleindienst betrifft, den hat man wiedergeholt und für den hat man Geld ausgegeben, weil der genau diesem Bild des Spielers entspricht, den Frank Schmidt gerne hätte. Und er hat ja auch nirgendwo so gut funktioniert wie in Heidenheim. Wobei ich eigentlich nicht gerne von Funktionieren spreie bei Spielern. Das finde ich immer so ein bisschen. Ja, mag ich eigentlich nicht so gern.
Es hat nirgendwo so gut zueinander gepasst wie vielleicht in Heidenheim. Und ich meine, da hat der Tim mit den zitierten Statistiken schon ein paar genannt, wo man das Gefühl haben könnte, dass die dem Trainer wichtig sein könnten. Meiste Zweikämpfe und so weiter. Das wundert einen nicht ganz so. Ja, wie haben sich denn dann die Strukturen verändert? Also, wenn du jetzt ja schon bis ins Jahr 94 zurückgehst, ich habe gerade panisch die letzten Platzierungen nachgeschlagen, die gingen auf der Seite dann nur bis 2006. Also, ich wurde nicht mal fündig. Was ist denn da in Heidenheim eigentlich passiert? Hat das mit Feu zu tun? Mit einem großen Unternehmen? Oder woher kommt dieser Aufstieg? Denn ja, schon die 2. Liga ist ja auch schon etwas Besonderes.
Das ist eine interessante Geschichte. Es hat eigentlich damit zu tun, dass Heidenheim schon zu diesen Zeiten fast schon zu erfolgreich war. Man wurde immer besser und besser, warum auch immer. Hier in der Region ist Fußball schon immer ein großes Thema gewesen. Und dann kam eben der Zeitpunkt, wo es darum ging, in die Regionalliga aufzusteigen. Und das gibt ja doch recht große Forderungen an die Vereine, wenn du das machen willst. Du brauchst halt eine Profi-Struktur. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt war in Heidenheim alles nur ehrenamtlich ausgelegt. Und aus dem Grund hat man dann eben beschlossen, man geht diesen Weg und spaltet sich ab vom Sportverein und gründet neu. Also 2007 hat man neu gegründet und nannte sich dann eben der 1. FC Heidenheim, hat die Zahl 1846 beibehalten.
Es ist ja auch lustig, dass man sich abspaltet und sich dann aber 1. FC Heidenheim nennt, so als wäre man zuerst da gewesen.
Ja, es ist schon eine merkwürdige Geschichte. Also warum auch immer werden wir ständig mit Hoffenheim verglichen, habe ich bis zum heutigen Tag nicht verstanden, woher das kommt, weil wir ja ganz weit weg von der Geschichte Hoffenheims sind. Und es ist ja immer so der Dorfverein – damit kann ich gut umgehen, wir sind ein Dorfverein im Prinzip – aber es wird einem so die Tradition immer abgesprochen. Das ist ja was ganz, ganz wichtiges im Fußball, dass der Verein entsprechend Tradition hat. Ich glaube, es gibt keinen Verein, der so viel Tradition hat wie die Heidenheimer tatsächlich. Da hat sich zwar der Name geändert, aber sonst hat sich tatsächlich gar nichts geändert. Es ist immer noch die gleiche Besetzung, es sind immer noch die gleichen Menschen, die da arbeiten, nur eben nicht mehr ehrenamtlich. Aber wenn du eben im Fußball hochkommen möchtest und wenn du aufsteigen möchtest, dann bleibt ja gar nichts anderes übrig, als das Ganze umzuwandeln. Das geht halt nur mal ehrenamtlich nicht. Und insofern hat man dann eben 2007 gestartet, was bedeutet, dass der Holger Sandweiz seit 28 Jahren an der Spitze steht. Also fing an als Abteilungsleiter in der Landesliga und ist eben jetzt Vorstandsvorsitzender. Und dann waren wir fürchterlich erfolgreich. Und dann ging das einfach Jahr für Jahr immer weiter hoch.
Das heißt, es hat quasi nicht mit externem Geld zu flüssen zu tun, sondern es war erst der sportliche Erfolg da. Und dann kamen dann auch Sponsoren und so weiter mit dazu.
Ja, genau. Der sportliche Erfolg war tatsächlich zuerst da. Also wir nennen das ja immer noch Alpstadion, die Feut Arena. Und bis 2007 war das noch – ich hatte da meine Bundesjugendspiele tatsächlich – das Öfteren, also noch mit Tartan-Bahn. Und erst 2007 wurde das umgebaut. Und erst mit dem Erfolg kam das Geld. Das ist tatsächlich so. Und das Prinzip war immer – es gibt quasi eine Art Sponsoren-Pyramide. Es sind mittlerweile rund about 500 Sponsoren, die das Ganze finanzieren. Die überwiegenden Sponsoren sind regional, aus dem direkten Umfeld. Es gibt dann so, kann man jetzt denken, wie man möchte, Platin und Silber und Gold und Bronze und wie das alles heißt. Du hast ganz oben mittlerweile diese Porsche Investoren-Tochter, MPH heißen die, glaube ich. Ich finde das so ein bisschen schwieriger Begriff. Ich kann mir den erzählen, ich mag ihn. Fand ich Hartmann deutlich besser. Hartmann hat zurückgezogen, also vom Trikot und befindet sich nur noch auf dem Armel. Freud ist ein großer Sponsor, aber das Ganze ist wirklich so aufgebaut, das sollte einer wegbrechen, niemandem Panik gerät. Also da hat sich da schon sehr unabhängig aufgestellt und Holger Sandwald ist auch sehr rührig, immer wieder neue Sponsoren zu finden und wir haben hier Supermärkte, Malerbetriebe, also wirklich der halbe Mittelstand engagiert sich da.
Und woher kam dann das Geld für den Start- und Umbau, weil das war ja dann, wenn ich es jetzt richtig verstanden habe, auch schon 2007, also zeitgleich fast.
Das Geld vom, also die Stadt Heidenheim hat tatsächlich sehr investiert in den Vereinen. Auch was sehr Umstrittenes über Jahre. Also es war hier eigentlich immer ein bisschen ein Problem. Also wir hatten sehr lange einen Oberbürgermeister, Bernhard Elk, der sehr verbunden war mit dem Verein und auch sehr viel unternommen hat, um Steuergelder entsprechend locker zu machen und den Gemeinderat zu überzeugen. Das war nicht immer wohl gelitten hier. Es gibt sehr viele andere Sportvereine, es gibt hier Hockey, Basketball, es gibt die Fechter und das war nichts, was den FC Heidenheim sonderlich beliebt gemacht hat, tatsächlich bei der Bevölkerung. Dann gab es diesen etwas unrühmlichen Abschnitt mit diesem Wohnkonzern Gakfar, was mir damals sehr übel aufgestoßen ist, dass man das Geld von der Gakfar quasi genommen hat, die sich dann das Namensrecht verkauft hat. Also es war nicht immer Feud-Arena. Nach dem Albstadion kam die Gakfar-Arena, allerdings nicht sehr lange. Dann hat der Feud das Namensrecht übernommen und das ist sicherlich auch besser so.
Also das heißt, es steht quasi finanziell auf ganz breiten Schultern, auf vielen Lokal-Sponsoren und eben einigen überregionalen, die man kennt und es ist quasi eine sportliche Erfolgsgeschichte, die sich dann wirtschaftlich übersetzt hat. Ich höre diese Geschichte zum ersten Mal. Na also in dieser Form. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass ich noch vor ein paar Jahren in einem anderen Podcast gehört habe, dass eigentlich das wesentliche Geld von Freud käme und so weiter. Wie oft passiert dir das, dass du das Gefühl hast, die Geschichte Heidenheims wird anders erzählt, als du sie erlebt hast und da du ja sehr nah mit dabei warst jetzt die ganze Zeit, müssen wir ja schon davon ausgehen. Also deine Perspektive ist sehr wahrscheinlich die detailliertere.
Das passiert mir immer. Also ich glaube, dass die Geschichte nicht wirklich jemanden interessiert, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Ich denke, Heidenheim ist kein Verein, mit dem er sich freiwillig beschäftigt, wenn man nicht unbedingt gegen ihn spielen muss. Das hat sich geändert in den letzten Jahren. Ich würde es aber an Frank Schmidt festmachen. Natürlich der Film von Joshua Pause, Trainer, der ihn bekannt gemacht hat. Dann ist das natürlich schon eine Story, die die Leute interessiert. Aber es macht sich, glaube ich, keiner die Mühe, mal dahinter zu gucken. Wobei, was man nicht vergessen darf und das möchte ich auch absolut nicht verschweigen, weil ich da sehr kritisch dem gegenüberstehe, ist die Geschichte mit Quattrex. Da weißt du wahrscheinlich mehr als ich oder bist besser informiert als ich. Auch Heidenheim hat von Quattrex Geld bekommen. Es sind angeblich seit 2016, spricht man von angeblich, 7 Millionen, die bisher geflossen sind. Im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen Vereinen macht Heuger Samuel da gar kein Hehl draus. Also der steht dazu und sagt, ja, wir haben von Quattrex Geld bekommen. Das ist gut so, weil ohne funktioniert es halt nicht. Ich meine auch Union Berlin hat Geld von Quattrex bekommen. Kaiserslautern hat Geld von Quattrex bekommen. Und die Geschichte mit dem VfB ist ja auch hinlänglich bekannt mit Wolfgang Dietrich.
Ja, und ich meine, das unterstreicht natürlich auch schon so eine gewisse Außensicht, zumindest von Investorenseite. Also es ist jetzt kein Zufall, dass Union und Heidenheim da Geld bekommen. Ich glaube, bei Lautern war es noch mal ein bisschen – bei Lautern, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere, war es damals, zum damaligen Zeitpunkt jetzt nicht mal, man dachte, die steigen die 1. Liga auf, sondern eher, um da auch einen Fuß in die Tür zu bekommen in diesen Verein. Da gab es eben ein Fenster, in dem man auch, glaube ich, günstig bei Lautern reingekommen ist, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere. Also es ist jetzt alles irgendwo im Rückenmark, hole ich jetzt gerade diese Informationen hoch. Aber Heidenheim und Union, das war eben mit dem Ziel, da einen Aufsteiger zu formen, bei dem man dann an den Gewinne mitbeteiligt wird, so wie es ja bei Union jetzt auch der Fall ist.
Übrigens auch der FC Nürnberg, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Nur haben die, glaube ich, mittlerweile das Engagement beendet, aber auch bei Nürnberg war Drecks mit drin.
Jetzt, also ich merke schon, ich könnte ja eigentlich ein Tribüngengespräch daraus machen. Ich muss mich jetzt sehr zügeln. Aber ich glaube, ein Thema müssen wir dann noch kurz ansprechen. Daher kommt vielleicht auch der Vergleich mit Hoffenheim. Du hast ja selber schon das Wort Dorfverein in den Mund genommen. Und das hat natürlich auch mit den Zuschauerzahlen zu tun. Also das Stadion selbst hat maximal 15.000. Und insgesamt liegt der Schnitt bei 10.000. Und das ist der drittschlechteste der zweiten Liga. Nur Regensburg und Sandhausen haben noch weniger im Schnitt in dieser Saison bisher gehabt. Ist denn das auch das Fan-Potenzial, wo du sagen würdest, das liegt in dieser Region? Gibt es da noch Möglichkeiten zu wachsen? Wie ist eigentlich genau die Region Heidenheim?
Sehr sportlich. Eine sehr sportliche Region. Sehr fußballorientiert. Aber man muss wissen, dass hier wirklich jedes Dorf seinen eigenen Fußballverein hat, dass viele bis in die Bezirksliga hochgehen. Ist natürlich jetzt für Bundesligischen lächerlich, bedeutet aber für die Menschen hier, dass sie jeden Sonntag auf den Sportplatz gehen und sich das Spiel angucken. Die Vereine haben alle – also es hat sich die letzten Jahre geändert. Zu Beginn war es eigentlich eher so, dass die regionalen Vereine auf den FC Heidenheim überhaupt nicht gut zu sprechen waren. Dann hattest du irgendwo ein paar talentierte Jugendliche, dann sind die irgendwann nach Heidenheim gegangen. Und dann war natürlich der ordentliche Abteilungsleiter nicht mehr sonderlich am Youth, dass er seine Spieler verliert. War großes Konkurrenzdenken einfach. Dann bist du sehr nah dran am SSV Ulm. Du bist sehr nah dran am VfA Ahlen. Und die waren vor Heidenheim eigentlich die erfolgreicheren Mannschaften. Du hast einfach diesen Pool nicht, wo du deine Fans rausziehen kannst. Genauso bist du sehr nah am VfB dran. Stuttgart ist nicht weit, das sind 80 Kilometer. Du bist sehr nah an München dran. Und hier ist es schon so, die Leute werden entweder als VfB-Fan oder als FC Bayern-Fan geboren. Das ist so eine familiäre Geschichte.
Das ist lustig, dass du Augsburg gar nicht erwähnst. Die wären ja eigentlich auch noch nah dran.
Das interessiert hier jetzt eigentlich so jemand.
Ich finde das völlig richtig, dass sie Augsburg nicht erwähnt.
Ich glaube, Augsburg hat jetzt nicht so die Lobby in Heidenheim.
Ich sage ja nur. Damit die Leute es grob verordnen können. Also es ist quasi in so einem sehr schiefen Vier-Eck gefangen zwischen Augsburg, Stuttgart, Ulm und Ahlen.
Und die Ulmer, der Weg, den die Ulmer gegangen sind, der Spekant, genauso das Ahlen, mittlerweile zum zweiten Mal ins Insolvenz gegangen. Und die werden nie nach Heidenheim abwandern. Also so wie ein Schalke-Fan nie Dortmund-Fan werden wird, so wird einer von SSV, Ulm sich nie für Heidenheim interessieren. Und dann bleiben einfach nicht mehr sehr viele Menschen übrig, die du dann als Fans rekrutieren könntest für diesen Verein.
Ja, ich bin echt extrem gespannt darauf, ob wir Heidenheim in der 1. Liga sehen und wie dann. Dann werden wahrscheinlich die ganzen Geschichten, die du uns jetzt erzählt hast, wahrscheinlich werden die dann ausgegraben und dann wird uns das alles erzählt. Es ist auf jeden Fall etwas Besonderes und in diesem Jahr ja auch wirklich mit vielen, vielen Toren gesegnet. Und auch wenn es mir schwerfällt, müssen wir aber auch noch über die anderen Vereine sprechen. Also es fällt mir nicht schwer wegen den Vereinen, sondern einfach nur, weil ich jetzt die Heidenheim-Story so interessant finde. Aber zum Glück ist ja beim FC St. Pauli, lieber Tim, auch etwas passiert, was man als durchaus interessant bezeichnen könnte und vielleicht verdeutlichen, dass diese Zahlen 8 Spiele, 8 Siege, 16 zu 3 Tore, dementsprechend logischerweise 24 Punkte. Und als wir das letzte Mal über St. Pauli gesprochen haben, ging es die ganze Zeit um Abstiegskampf, Abstiegskampf, was kann da noch passieren? Jetzt schaue ich auf die Tabelle. St. Pauli Platz 5, 41 Punkte. Sind zwar noch 8 Punkte auf einen Verein aus der Nachbarschaft, auf Rang 3, aber was ist da los, Tim?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Also der FC St. Pauli hat ja im Winter unter – man kann es nicht anders sagen – unter einem großen Aufschrei nicht nur unter St. Pauli-Fans, sondern auch allgemein so in Fußballdeutschland hat man viele Fragen gekriegt, warum Timo Schulz entlassen wurde. Timo Schulz wurde entlassen, Fabian Hürzler, einer seiner beiden Co-Trainer, hat übernommen. Er hat es tatsächlich geschafft, der Mannschaft einen defensiven Spielstil einzuimpfen. Das finde ich persönlich schon ziemlich beeindruckend, wie er das geschafft hat. Ich hätte vorher nicht unbedingt gedacht, dass das funktioniert. Timo Schulz wurde immer ein relativ offensiver Spielstil propagiert und auch mutig nach vorne gespielt. Aber defensiv wackelte das immer und irgendwie wurde das jetzt geschafft.
Sag doch einfach 4 zu 4 gegen KSC am 17. Spieltag. Das war ja das letzte Spiel vor dem Winter. Das war doch Timo Schulz Fußball.
Genau, die Frage ist ja – man muss ja dazu sagen – ich habe mit Timo Schulz ja auch eine mehr oder weniger persönliche Geschichte. Ich habe das sehr eng verfolgt. Der Millanturn ist in der Zeit, in der Timo Schulz Trainer gewesen ist. Bei St. Pauli ist er sehr groß geworden. Da haben wir den Millanturn professionalisiert. Ich habe das sehr eng verfolgt. Ich habe auch viele Einblicke in den Verein bekommen. Wir haben ein großes Podcastprojekt mit Timo Schulz gemacht. Und da muss man dann schon irgendwann vielleicht auch ein bisschen fragen, wie ist denn eigentlich der eigene Abstand zu der Person. Auch Timo Schulz sieht man da irgendwas nicht. Wird man da so ein bisschen betriebsblind oder will man da vielleicht Dinge auch nicht sehen? Was bei Timo Schulz auf jeden Fall, was man sagen kann, ist, dass er ein bisschen konservativ in seine Entscheidung gewesen ist. Er hat lange gebraucht, um sich von der Raute, die ja eigentlich fast das ganze Jahr 2022 oder zumindest Teile des Jahres 2022 nicht funktioniert hat, davon ab zu verabschieden. Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, dass er auch nicht die Spieler zur Verfügung hatte, die jetzt da sind. Also es ist tatsächlich, was diese Siegesserie momentan ausmacht, da sind drei Sachen im Grunde drin. Zum einen ist es eine neue taktische Ausrichtung, ein sehr klarer Defensivfokus mit einer Fünferkette, drei Innenverteidiger, die da mit dabei sind. Davon ist einer neu zugegangen. Dann hat man jetzt einen offensiven Außenspieler mit Dapo Afullayan, der unfassbar gut ist und dem Team richtig, richtig gut tut. Und dann hat man eben auch Spieler wie Eric Smit, der von der sechsten Position in die Innenverteilung gerückt ist. Jakov Medic als Innenverteidiger, der war ja schon im Sommer, war da ja schon gefühlt mit mehr als eineinhalb Füßen in Stuttgart. Der war lange verletzt auch in der Hinrunde. Der ist jetzt wieder fit und zurück. Und so flügt sich das irgendwie zusammen. Eine neue taktische Ausrichtung. Ich würde sie, da man ja auch beim Rasenfunk häufiger mal das mit Bundesliga-Fußball vergleichen kann, ich würde das dieses 5-2-3 eher so als so ein System Eintracht Frankfurt bezeichnen. Und da hat man dann eben auch die richtigen Spieler drin, die so auch in der Art und Weise, Zusammensetzung auch in der Hinrunde gar nicht verfügbar waren. Und dann hat Fabian Hürzeler auch noch so ein paar Kniffe gehabt. Conor Metcalf, der ja das erste halbe Jahr schon ein bisschen gebraucht hat. Der kam ja aus der australischen Liga, aus der ersten Liga da. Das kann man, glaube ich, so vergleichen mit dritter Liga in Deutschland. Der hat ein bisschen gebraucht, um anzukommen. Ist eigentlich ein Achter, spielt jetzt rechts offensiv auf der Außenbahn, macht das richtig, richtig gut. Aber es gibt auch bei den einzelnen Partien, wenn man sich das anschaut, da gab es auch einiges an Matchglück. Und der Auftakt in Nürnberg, da wurde 1-0 gewonnen. Ich glaube, Nürnberg hat 25- 26-mal das Tor geschossen, St. Pauli 5-mal oder 6-mal oder so. Das war schon ein bisschen glücklich. Da gab es noch einige Spiele mehr. Jetzt hat Greuther Fürth das System von St. Pauli geknackt und ziemlich gut unter Druck gesetzt. Die haben selbst in Unterzahl ein sehr gutes Spiel gegen St. Pauli gemacht. Ich würde schon sagen, 8 Siege davon sind auf jeden Fall 5 hoch verdient, aber 3, da würde ich ein kleines Fragezeichen hinter machen und sagen, ja, da war auch schon ein bisschen Glück dabei. Das muss man auch ganz ehrlich sagen, das hat dem FC St. Pauli in der Hinrunde auch massiv gefehlt. Also eine neue taktische Formation, Spielglück, aber auch die Spieler sind momentan vorhanden. Und das sind jetzt 80er in Folge und ja, klar, jetzt guckt man natürlich nach oben, aber man muss ja auch realistisch sein. Also Heidenheim, HSV und Darmstadt, die sind diese Saison auch einfach richtig stark. Die haben auch schon richtig, richtig viele Punkte geholt. Und jetzt noch 8 Punkte aufholen auf den HSV. Klar, es ist Frühling, da kann schon noch was schiefgehen und so. Aber dafür müsste St. Pauli schon jetzt eine Rückrunde spielen, die irgendwie über 40 Punkte in 17 Spielen bedeutet. Und das ist schon echt ganz schön weit. Aber mein Gott, die haben jetzt 24 schon geholt aus 8 Spielen. Also wer weiß, was kommt.
Ja, und ihr habt ja noch die Spiele gegen alle drei. Zwei bei allen drei auswärts. Also bei gut, ich weiß nicht, ob man HSV auswärts bezeichnen darf, aber auf jeden Fall Darmstadt und Heidenheim. Klar ist jetzt auch nicht selbstverständlich, dass das läuft. Es geht jetzt dann los, also nach der Länderspielpause erst zu Hause gegen den Jahn und dann eben in Heidenheim, dann das nächste Auswärtsspiel ist dann in Hamburg und dann wiederum das nächste Auswärtsspiel ist eben in Darmstadt. Das heißt Anfang Mai ist es entweder vorbei und man kann die Saison dann doch relativ entspannt austruten lassen, weil man einfach froh sein muss, dass die Abstiegssorgen so schnell vorbei gegangen sind. Oder ihr seid halt so richtig drin in der Verlosung.
Ja, und da gibt es tatsächlich, man glaubt es ja kaum, aber es gibt so ein, zwei Stimmen, die gesagt haben, so jetzt das letzte Spiel gegen Sandhausen. Das war ja unfassbar gut, aber da hätte man vielleicht einfach mal unentschieden spielen müssen. Dann wäre diese Aufstiegshoffnung, die wären so ein bisschen begraben gewesen. Und da hätte man sich zumindest darauf konzentrieren. Ja, also ich gehöre da auf jeden Fall nicht zu. Aber das hat man schon vernommen. Dann hätte man sich darauf konzentrieren können, den Kader weiter auszubauen, aufzubauen, weil da wird ja auch einiges passieren. Lea Pakarada, für mich der beste Linksverteidiger der Liga, der geht ja nach Köln. Ein, zwei weitere Spieler, da gibt es sicherlich auch Interesse. Das heißt, da wird auch am Kader über den Sommer einiges passieren. Und da ist es für so Zweite-Ligisten ja immer schon ganz gut, wenn man in der Länderspielpause, die jetzt gerade ist, wenn man da schon so eine Sicherheit hat, dass man in der Folgelsaison auch schon weiß, in welcher Ligamann unterwegs ist. Und da gab es schon so ein, zwei, die da eher in die Richtung gedacht haben, ich persönlich, ich sitze da im Hypetrain und will das Ding komplett durchziehen, so ungefähr.
Ja, alles andere wäre ja auch komisch. Ich würde gerne die anderen beiden mal noch mit dazuzuholen. Robert, du hast jetzt am längsten geschwiegen, weil ja auch der Jahn der nächste Gegner von St. Pauli ist. Ein Heimspiel für St. Pauli, auswärts für Regensburg. Wie blickst du denn auf diese Serie, die da auf einmal gestartet wurde?
Ja, jetzt haben ja beide eine Serie gestartet quasi. Also es wird schon sehr interessant und bei Pauli kann immer alles passieren. Entweder hauen wir sie 3-0 weg oder sie hauen uns 3-0 weg. Also es ist da, könnte auf jeden Fall ein spannendes Spiel sein.
Und danach dann gegen 15.000 euphorisierte Fans in – jetzt habe ich den Namen, der nicht der Sponsornname ist, des Heidenheimer Stadions vergessen, Petras. Hilf mir.
Das Alpstadion.
Alpstadion, genau. Danach dann gegen Heidenheim. Wie hast du das beobachtet? Ich meine, du bist ja auch eine sehr genaue Kennerin der 2. Männerliga.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, ich finde das sehr spannend. Ich freue mich auf das Spiel, habe aber schon ein kleines bisschen Bauchweh tatsächlich, weil St. Pauli natürlich auch eine Art Spielart hat. Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass da zwei aufeinander zurennen und dass das eine ganz, ganz spannende Geschichte wird. Zumal ich auch finde, dass in St. Pauli wirklich gute Kicker unterwegs sind, die ja auch technisch was drauf haben. Das wird sicher ein sehr, sehr spannendes Spiel. Ich würde mich wahnsinnig freuen, wenn St. Pauli es noch packt. Also ich fände so einen dritten Relegationsplatz, der würde mir ziemlich gut gefallen tatsächlich. Den würde ich sehr gerne nehmen. Also wir auf der 2. St. Pauli auf der 3. Und der Rest ist Schweiß.
Ich teile das auf jeden Fall. Also ich freue mich da auf das Spiel in Heidenheim. Da freue ich mich auch schon sehr drauf. Das Lieblingswort, das habe ich jetzt so auf den Pressekonferenzen von Fabian Hürzler so vernommen, das Lieblingswort von ihm ist Konterabsicherung. Das ist ja tatsächlich etwas, was den ersten FC Heidenheim ja ausmacht. Ich würde behaupten, dass es nach Ballgewinn die schnellste Mannschaft der ganzen Liga ist. Und entsprechend wird das da auf jeden Fall echt spitz auf knapp sein. Also da treffen dann so zwei Teams aufeinander, die genau da beide den Fokus drauf haben, beziehungsweise St. Pauli dann defensiv, Heidenheim offensiv. Und da muss man mal schauen. Max, du hattest vorhin gesagt, St. Pauli hat Probleme gegen Dreierketten. Das war jetzt total spannend. St. Pauli hat jetzt tatsächlich gegen sieben von acht Teams gespielt, die mit einer Dreierkette agiert haben und dann halt sieben gewonnen. Das achte Team, was dann mit einer Viererkette gespielt hat, da haben sich auch viele gefragt, warum sie das überhaupt gemacht haben. Es war jetzt an tausend und die haben ja dann entsprechend auch das gespürt, dass das nicht so eine gute Idee war. Also diese Problematik mit Dreierketten, da möchte ich fast sagen, die ist immer noch nicht ganz gebannt, aber es ist halt auch einfach der aktuelle Trend in der 2. Liga. Es ist halt total Richtung Dreierkette. Also da sind ja alle raufgegangen auf die Formationen, ob das jetzt Darmstadt ist, die in dieser Saison raufgegangen sind. Sogar der 1. FC Nürnberg spielt jetzt inzwischen ja, dadurch, dass Kastrop dann ja eher so ein Schienenspieler ist. Er spielt ja mit so einer quasi Fünferkette. Und auch jetzt im Saisonverlauf haben dann noch viele Teams da, ihre Viererketten. Auch Greuther führt ja, gutes Beispiel, Viererkette mit Rauthe wieder aufgelöst. Und jetzt unter Zorniger spielen die auch mit einer Dreierkette. Also das ist so ein allgemeiner Trend in der Liga. Und ich glaube, der FC St. Pauli ist so das erste Team, was richtig gute Lösungen gefunden hat, jetzt gegen gegnerische Dreierketten mit so einer starken Mannorientierung. Die haben da ein sehr gutes Positionsspiel zusammen. Paccarada löst auf in den 6er-Raum. Laschner ist sowieso ein sehr flexibler Spieler da vorne im Sturm. Dann haben sie da die beiden Achter, Hartl und Irvine, die auch immer ihre Position auflösen. Eric Smit ist, was Spielverständnis angeht, aus meiner Sicht einer der besten Aufbauspieler der ganzen Liga. Er hat auch einen ganz feinen Fuß. Die ziehen da ein echt gutes Positionsspiel auf. Das funktioniert auch gerade gegen diese Dreierketten mit viel Mannorientierung, was so Kaiserslautern und so spielen. Da gibt es noch ein paar Teams, die so etwas anbieten und gegen die St. Pauli jetzt tatsächlich endlich Lösung gefunden hat.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich bin von uns auch gespannt, weil wir haben es ja letztes Jahr mal probiert, mit einer Dreierkette gegen St. Pauli zu starten. Und nach 11 Minuten stand es 2-0 für Pauli. Also das ist krass in die Hose gegangen damals.
Ja, aber ich meine, das war ja ein ganz interessantes Spiel, weil St. Pauli ja mit Achung Krach den Vorsprung über die Zeit gebracht hat. 3-2 haben sie ja damals in Regensburg gewonnen. Und da fand ich das total bemerkenswert, dass sogar der Jahn Regensburg – dass ihr sogar auf eine Dreierkette gegangen seid. Also wie krass das damals schon gewesen ist, wie klar damals schon war, dass der FC St. Pauli mit seiner Rauhte Probleme gegen Dreierketten haben. Und dass dann sogar so jemand wie Mersad Selimbegovic, der ja eigentlich so ein – hat er das danach überhaupt noch mal versucht, also jemals wieder eine Dreierkette spielen zu lassen? Oder ist das jetzt – also macht er das jetzt auch inzwischen? Oder was geht denn da ab in Regensburg dann jetzt?
Gab es ein paar Versuche, aber hauptsächlich wegen Personalmangel diese Saison. Bei uns ist ja fast die ganze Innenverteidigung, die Außenverteidigung ausgefallen. Dann gab es schon ab und zu mal so Dreierketten. Wir hätten eigentlich auch die Spieler für die Dreierkette, aber irgendwie kriegen sie es dann am Ende doch nicht gebacken, wenn sie es dann doch mal spielen müssen. Aber von den Namen her müssten wir eigentlich eine gute Dreierkettenmannschaft sein. Aber sobald man es dann auf den Platz bringt, klappt es eigentlich so gut wie nie. Das hat mal zu einem Unentschieden gegen Kiel gereicht bei einer Dreierkette.
Ich meine, wenn man jetzt Eric Smit von St. Pauli nimmt, der ja so eigentlich ein Sechser ist, der dann in die zentrale Innenverteidigungsposition defensiv wechselt und offensiv dann wieder ein klassischen Sechser spielt, das ist ja eigentlich Maximilian Thalhammer bei euch in Regensburg, oder?
Ja, eigentlich schon, aber der ist irgendwie immer noch nicht angekommen. Also er war ja früher bei uns und ist weggegangen. Und jetzt ist er wieder zurückgekommen. Und ich dachte mir, geiler Transfer, also Maschine. Und bis jetzt hat er seinen Maschinenstatus noch nicht gezeigt. Und das ist wirklich ärgerlich, weil so einen kannst du eigentlich gebrauchen beim Jahn. Und als wir es gegen euch versucht haben, hat halt Gimba und Kennedy überhaupt gar nicht gewusst, was ihr Auftrag war in der Dreierkette. Und es hat schon sehr peinlich ausgesehen.
Da wurden jetzt Flashbacks getriggert. Wir sind aber auch schon mittendrin im Regensburg-Segment, Robert. Also wenn ich dich jetzt so reden höre, dann verstehe ich noch nicht, warum jetzt – du hast jetzt von der Serie gesprochen, da war ich schon total erstaunt. Ich glaube, du meintest damit die Serie, die gerade im Wachsen begriffen ist. Also zwei Siege sehe ich jetzt in den letzten beiden Spielen. Ja, nur weil du gesagt hast, wir haben ja St. Pauli und wir, wir haben ja eine Serie gestanden. Ich dachte so, Moment mal, wie oft haben die gewonnen? Noch mal nachgeguckt, zweimal. Okay, also eure bemerkenswerte Serie, die ja aber immerhin dafür gesorgt hat, dass ihr jetzt bei 26 Punkten steht und damit ja wirklich einen wichtigen Schritt gemacht habt. Also dahinter liegen gerade Bielefeld, Braunschweig und Rostock, jeweils 25 Punkte und Sandhausen mit 21 Punkten. Also sprich, diese sechs Punkte, ich will jetzt auch nicht kleinreden, ist zwar ein kleines Särchen, aber es hat zu einer Wiederbelebung im Tabellenkeller gesorgt. Was sind die Gründe dafür? War das – vorhin hat ja Tim das schon so ein bisschen so aufgedröselt, da hatten wir Taktik, da hatten wir neue Spieler, da hatten wir Spielglück. Woran liegt es beim Jahn, dass es jetzt mal besser lief?
Also erstmal möchte ich sagen, es ist ja erstaunlich, wir waren das allererste Mal auf dem letzten Platz nach sechs Jahren 2. Liga, weil wir ja auch immer so als die Absteiger schlechthin betitelt werden. Also für uns war das auch eine ungewohnte Situation. Und ja, ich kann es so gar nicht sagen, also es war eine Mischung aus sehr vielen. Ich glaube, wir haben die Winterpause so ein bisschen verkackt, das waren zu viele verletzt, zu wenig eingespieltheit, dann haben sich noch wieder mehr verletzt, wir mussten ständig durchwechseln. Unsere Kader-Zusammenstellung war mangelhaft, also dadurch fällt ein Innenverteidiger quasi aus und dadurch ist unsere ganze Viererkette kaputt. Das hätte halt auch nicht sein dürfen. Eben unsere Legende, der Bastel-Nachreiner als Innenverteidiger Gott, hat zwei kapitale Fehler gemacht, die zu zwei Niederlagen führen. Dann hast du vorne den Sturm, der nicht trifft und immer wieder Pech. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Pfosten-Schüsse wir seit dem Hannover-Spiel hatten und gegen Kiel hatten wir dann einfach mal auch Spielglück. Also das hätten wir im Gegensatz zum Karlsruhe-Spiel vielleicht gar nicht gewinnen dürfen, haben es aber dann gewonnen. Und gegen Paderborn hat man dann gesehen, dass das Selbstbewusstsein absolut wieder zurückgekehrt ist und wir dadurch eigentlich verdient gewonnen hätten, aber dann wieder typisch Jahn in der 96. Minute nochmal so eine hundertprozentige Chance für Paderborn zugelassen haben. Und wir haben es im Podcast gesagt, ja, vor drei Wochen oder so wäre das sicher drin gewesen und da hätte man noch das 1-1 kassiert. Und das ist halt jetzt der Trend is your friend, wie ein berühmter Mensch über den du ein Buch geschrieben hast, mal gesagt hat. Und ja, so schaut es ja gerade aus. Also und ich denke, dass das halt jetzt gerade auch alles stimmungsmäßig in Regensburg ändert. Und wir hätten den Trend vielleicht schon gegen Hannover 96 starten müssen, weil da hättest du eigentlich aus meiner Sicht gewinnen müssen gegen diese wirklich schlechte Hannoveraner Mannschaft, die bei uns aufgetreten ist. Aber da waren wir halt noch da, Jan ist auch ein Depp, so wie der Klub so ein bisschen. Aber besser spät als nie und ich vielleicht haben wir es jetzt wirklich zum richtigen Zeitpunkt gestartet. Aber so in der Nachberatung war der hauptsächliche Grund für mich, dass wir besser geworden sind, dass vor allem in der Viererkette die Verletzten zurückgekommen sind und auch dann Spielpraxis und Eingespieltheit hatten, weil die verändern halt alles und unser Kader war halt in der Mitte der Saison nicht breit genug, um diese Verletzungen abzufangen und dann haben wir halt oft auf den Sack bekommen und eben auch recht hoch. Heidenheim 5-4 zum Beispiel, also oder gegen Rostock 3-0, das kennt man eigentlich von unserer Viererkette nicht, wenn sie in Vollbesetzung ist.
Ja, aber 5-4 auf den Sack bekommen, das haben wir ja dann auch. Also finde ich jetzt ein erstaunliches Ergebnis.
Ja, aber das war halt auch ein psychischer Knacks für mich auch persönlich. Ich habe es live kommentiert. Noch völlige Eskalation auf der Presse-Tribüne beim 4 zu 4.
Minute muss man dazu sagen.
Genau. Und dann Anstoß, Ball auf die linke Seite, flanke Kopfball, Tor. Und ich lag nur noch da, unglaublich. Der Radiokommentator vom SBR bei euch oder so hat mich beinahe in die Arme genommen.
Ein Traum.
Also es ist Wahnsinn gewesen. Und da dachte ich halt, wie soll man aus diesem Erlebnis wieder rauskommen? Jetzt haben wir es, glaube ich, geschafft, zumindest psychisch, das zu überwinden nach wie vielen Niederlagen dazwischen, fünf Niederlagen und ein Unentschieden.
Der FC Heidenheim, die Nemesis für den Jahn.
Ja, ich habe schon echt Sorge, dass das am letzten Spieltag noch um was geht für beide von uns. Und dann werden wir alt aussehen.
Schauen wir mal.
Das ist ja noch ein bisschen hin. Aber was ja das Erstaunliche ist, ist ja unter anderem Name, den du schon so nonchalant hat fallen lassen, nämlich Merset Selimbegovic, der immer noch Trainer beim Jahn ist. Und ich habe immer den Eindruck, für dich ist das überhaupt nicht so unlogisch. Und ist ja klar, das hast du, glaube ich, auch schon das letzte Mal erzählt, als wir hier im Kurzpass waren. Weil da gab es nämlich auch schon Diskussionen rund um ihn. Ist es wirklich so, dass quasi national Selimbegovic viel mehr in der Kritik steht und sein Stuhl wackeliger ist, als es dann in Regensburg tatsächlich der Fall ist?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Weil wer soll ihn rausspeisen? Der Weggang von Christian Keller hat schon zu einem Machtvakuum so ein bisschen geführt. Ja, und jetzt auch im DFL-Vorstand mitgewählt. Er ist ein klasse Überperformer und er hat uns natürlich auch dahin gebracht, wo wir jetzt sind. Und wir tun uns sehr schwer, ihn zu ersetzen. Auf jeden Fall. Und wer jetzt noch übrig ist im Aufsichtsrat, ist Hans Rothammer. Ein treuer Mensch, der zu Keller gehalten hat und Keller hat eben Merzad reingebracht. Und Merzad hat sehr, sehr viel Rückhalt in der Geschäftsstelle. Ich glaube, niemand redet schlecht über ihn, von allen Mitarbeitern, der Vorstand nicht. Und jeder traut ihm zu, dass er diesen Verein ja leiten kann, auch so ein bisschen. Also er ist sehr mächtig in der ganzen Konstellation und deswegen eben mein labidater Ausspruch, wer soll ihn draus werfen.
Aber gab es nicht vor nicht mal einem Monat oder so, habe ich, meine ich, in der Konferenz, als ich die Konferenz gekocht habe, so ein fettes Banner gesehen zu haben, bei euch im Stadion, wo Merzad draus drauf stand. Ist das nicht vor ein paar Wochen erst gewesen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall, da hast du recht, gut beobachtet, aber für uns nicht ausschlaggebender als Fan, sagen wir es mal so, weil das ist halt hinter der Westtribüne, wo ich halt – ja, es ist jetzt böse, aber da hocken halt die Rentner und die haben sich halt…
Moment mal, die Rentner bringen bei euch Tapeten mit.
Tatsächlich, ja. Also ich meine, ich weiß nicht, in Bayern gibt es ja das Grantlertum. Man ist ja mit nie was zufrieden und man tut ja über alles meckern. Und da hocken schon ziemliche Grantler, auch wenn ich jetzt wieder auf den Sack bekomme, wenn ich dann mich da blicken lasse. Aber die haben sich auch damals schon mit Bayerlorzer angelegt, dass der halber als auf die Tribüne gesprungen ist und ihn aufs Bau gehauen hat. Und jetzt wünschen sie sich ihn wieder zurück. Also die haben halt schon eine viel, viel, ja, was heißt kritischere, aber andere Haltung als die Ultras, sagt man es mal so, als die die Leute, die auf dem Stehplätz in der Hans-Jakob-Tribüne stehen. Da ist schon das Credo, wir wissen immer noch, wo wir herkommen. Und für uns ist, wir sehen nicht, dass Mercer die Mannschaft verloren hat. Und wir wissen, dass unser Kader eben nicht mehr hergibt. Und solange wir rechnerisch nicht abgestiegen sind, halten wir die Fresse und supporten die Mannschaft. Und das hat auch immer ganz gut geklappt und klappt hoffentlich dieses Jahr auch wieder. Aber es gibt natürlich auch eine wachsende Anzahl an Leute im Jahn-Umfeld. Christian Keller hat sie mal in einem Interview Jahn-Beobachter genannt. Die fordern, wir sollen jetzt endlich mal aufhören, in die Steine zu investieren und halt mal vernünftige Spieler kaufen und Superstürmer kaufen, damit wir quasi sicher immer in der 2. Liga bleiben. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Gemengelage. Aber die Ultras stehen auch zu 100 Prozent hinterm Ehrsatz, egal was jetzt dieses Jahr passieren würde, glaube ich.
Also das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass das nicht die Ultras sind, die da irgendwelche Transparente mitbringen, sondern dass es dann die Tener-Lady-Ultras sind, die da ihre Transparente mitbringen. Wie stehst denn du dann der Gesamtkonstellation gerade gegenüber? Also Christian Keller ist ein herber Verlust, vor allem weil er ja auch einen Blick für Transfers hatte. Das war immer schon Teil des Erfolgs beim Jahn, dass man für sehr wenig Geld sich Spieler holt, mit denen man eben dann auch meistens relativ souverän in der 2. Liga bestehen kann.
Ja, nachdem er quasi uns in die Regionalliga geführt hat, weil er am Anfang auch seinen Kader überschätzt hat. Aber aus diesen Fehler hat er gelernt. Das zeichnet Christian Keller auf jeden Fall aus. Jemand, der auf seinen Fehlern lernt und nicht stoisch dann so weiter macht und denkt, ich bin eh glüger als alle anderen. Und ja, dieses Vakuum ist jetzt riesig und ich habe schon große Sorge, auch nächstes Jahr. Ich glaube, wir haben noch acht Spieler mit Vertrag für nächstes Jahr. Also wir müssen fast einen neuen, kompletten Kader aufbauen. Und gerade eben, also vor wenigen Wochen, sind die zwei Chefscouts gegangen eben zu Köln. Hat der Keller die zu sich geholt. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob sie ersetzt ist. Tatsächlich, ich kann es jetzt hier ankündigen. Also meine Podcast-Förder wissen es auch. Am Montag habe ich mit Tobi Werner eine Podcast-Session. Dann erhoffe ich mir, dass ich ein paar glückliche oder frühe Nachrichten habe. Der hat natürlich jetzt auch einen 24-Stunden-Tag, aber wir müssen Scouts ersetzen. Wir müssen wirklich die ganze Mannschaft ersetzen. Wir wissen noch nicht, für welche Liga. Das ist eine absolute Herkules-Aufgabe. Und Huwe Werner ist jetzt auch erst 37, hat vielleicht auch noch nicht so viel Sportdirektor-Erfahrung. Wird eine harte, harte Aufgabe, egal, wo wir nächstes Jahr spielen.
Und würdest du denn dann – Entschuldigung, Max, weil das auch ein bisschen FC St. Pauli Bezug hat – Roger Stilz war ja neuer Sportchef. Das wurde ja auch geteilt, diese Position von Christian Keller. Der war ja Kaufmanager und sportlicher Leiter, glaube ich, bei euch irgendwie, ne?
Ja, genau, es wurde dann geteilt, als er gegangen ist. Also Christian Keller war quasi der allumfassende Jahn Gott. Jetzt haben wir einen Hausner Geschäftsführung. Der war aber auch schon länger da und kennt sich aus. Der macht einen super guten BWLer-Job. Also einen besseren BWLer kann man vielleicht auch nicht finden. Und die Sportdirektor-Stelle, ja, also ich sage jetzt immer, wir sind seit zwei Jahren ohne Sportdirektor. Also im letzten halben Jahr hat der Christian Keller auch nicht viel gemacht. Also es gab keine Vertragsverlängerung von ihm. Dann kam Roger Stilz und musste auf einmal auch so einen Scherbenhaufen übernehmen an Vertragsverlängerungen und Ausläufen. Er hat also ein paar gute Transfers getätigt, aber ich sage halt immer, das waren die tiefhängenden Früchte, weil das war halt eben Talhammer-Rückholung, Mähs-Rückholung, alles, was so quasi auch einfach war. Und dann kamen so ein paar Panikkäufe, ja? Fiesinger zum Beispiel, der bis jetzt so gut wie gar nicht gespielt hat, aber eine Sturmhoffnung sein sollte. Und dann halt der kapitale Fehler, dass er vergessen hat, Sing anzumelden und der deswegen die ganze Hinrunde nicht spielen durfte. Und ich meine, Sing ist halt unser Unterschiedsspieler. Dadurch ist er halt gegangen worden, sagt man es mal so. Es heißt zwar immer auf eigenen Wunsch, aber wir wissen alle, dass es nicht der eigene Wunsch war. Deswegen hat er für mich auch keine sehr gute Arbeit geleistet, sondern nur das gemacht, was notwendig war, aber nicht den Kader vorangebracht hat in dem Sinne. Vor allem ist er auch brutal unausgewogen, wie ich am Anfang gesagt habe. Es fehlt einen Innenverteidiger, es hat eigentlich noch einen Stürmer gefehlt. Wir haben Tausende Außenstürmer, wo aber keiner richtig gut ist. Also bis auf die Mitte sind wir echt unterbesetzt. Und Talhammer und Gimbal, wenn einer ausfällt, dann weiß man auch nicht, wen man da reinbringt. Da hat Mercer jetzt absolut basteln müssen, hat jetzt geschafft, Idrisi zum Beispiel zu integrieren. Aber das sind halt immer die Herkules-Aufgaben, die du unter der Saison machen musst, während du oft Spiele verlierst. Also ohne diese Ruhe der Ultras, wären wir wahrscheinlich jetzt auch ein absoluter Chaos-Club. Deswegen bin ich sehr, sehr froh, dass nur die West-Tribüne die Banner mitnimmt.
Das hört sich auch nicht so unkaotisch an, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich habe ja vorhin auch Wachtmarkum gesagt, und das ist immer noch so. Und ich sehe gerade auch nicht, dass Tobi Werner das füllt, aber es liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass er gerade im Hintergrund arbeitet wie der Berserker und deswegen nach vorne nichts sagen kann. Aber wie ich schon vorhin gesagt habe, das ist mit der heißen Nadel gestrickt, oder wie man es sagt.
Ja, und für alle, die sich fragen, ja, es ist der Tobi Werner, der früher bei Augsburg und Stuttgart unter anderem gespielt hat. Und das ist, glaube ich, seine erste Position als quasi nach der Karriere größere, oder?
Ja, er war vorher bei Jena und da gab es ja auch ein bisschen Turmulte. Und dann ist er zu uns geflohen, würde ich jetzt mal so behaupten.
Aber wie würdest du denn dann die generelle Situation oder Position von Regensburg beschreiben? Also wir haben jetzt schon gehört, es wird schwierig, sowohl jetzt dieses Jahr als auch mit Blick auf nächstes Jahr. Und das hat dann viel eben auch mit jemandem wie Christian Keller zu tun. Ich habe aber ja vorhin auch schon zitiert, also der Jan ist jetzt auch nicht der Zuschauermagnet, war er jetzt auch noch nie in der 2. Liga. Und man steht aber insgesamt eigentlich ganz gut da, nach all den Jahren, die man jetzt auch schon zum Teil 2. Liga-Luft schnuppern durfte. Also im Rohergebnis – also ich habe jetzt hier die Zahlen von 2021, das sind ja die letzten, die bekannt gegeben wurden von der DFL – da hat man 22 Millionen Euro erlöst in der Saison, das ist Platz 31, das heißt noch gut in der 2. Liga. Und beim Personalaufwand, der nur bei 10 Millionen Euro lag in dieser Saison, insgesamt lag man immerhin auf Platz 33. Also eigentlich ist das ja schon ein okayes 2. Liga-Niveau, mit dem man zwar absteigen kann, aber auch drin bleiben möglich ist. Ist das auch so deiner Meinung nach die Situation, in der sich Regensburg jetzt auch sportlich immer befinden sollte? Also im Grunde unteres Ende, 2. Liga, obere Tabellenhälfte, 3.
Das hoffe ich, dass wir uns da langsam etablieren. Ziel vor ein paar Jahren war es immer noch, also in den Top 50 der deutschen Mannschaften zu sein. Das war, glaube ich, realistisch, aber in der Zwischenzeit haben wir halt unser Trainingsgelände neu gebaut, den Kaulbacher Weg. Der war halt vorher, ja, also ich glaube der Tobi Schweinsteiger, der Bruder von Bastian, hat auch gemeint, es ist halt teilweise auch eklig da in dieser Dusche überhaupt zu duschen. So war der Status noch vor zehn Jahren und jetzt haben wir da ein ultramodernes Trainingsgelände mit sehr modernen Plätzen, teilweise auch mit Rasenheizung, Trainingsplätze, das ist, wie sonst, sind wir zum Schneeschieben hingegangen, dass sie überhaupt trainieren konnten, die Fans. Also es hat sich absolut was geändert in der Hoffnung, dass es eben dazu reicht, mindestens eine Fahrstuhlmannschaft zur 2. Liga zu sein. Und jetzt gerade im Moment gibt es ein Grundstück fürs Nachwuchsleistungszentrum, ein bisschen außerhalb der Stadt. Das wäre unser nächstes Ding und je länger man natürlich in der 2. Liga bleibt, desto schneller kann man dieses NLZ vielleicht sogar mit Internat hochziehen. Und das ist unser Ziel, ja, also auch über die Infrastruktur dann den Anspruch zu haben, vielleicht, ja, 2. Liga dauerhaft zu spielen. Aber gerade im Moment würde ich halt sagen, keine Ahnung, Top 40, Top 35, das ist unser Anspruch, würde ich sagen. Und wir sind halt ruhige Arbeiter, deswegen kennt man uns vielleicht auch in Deutschland nicht und sind diese graue Maus. Aber genau das ist, glaube ich, unser Erfolgserlebnis. Während jetzt hat, keine Ahnung, Hansa Rostock, der Meinung war, irgendwann auf Platz 9 den Trainer rauszuschmeißen und dann Letzter zu werden und wieder ihren Trainer rauszuschmeißen, haben wir halt einfach Ruhe bewahrt in der Hoffnung, dass es klappt und es schaut ganz gut aus, dass es klappt. Und ich glaube, das ist auch unser Erfolgskonzept, ja? Wissen, wo wir herkommen. So blöd, wie es klingt, auch wenn das sechste Jahr der 2. Liga, wir wissen immer noch, wo wir herkommen.
Das sind wir uns ja dann sehr ähnlich.
Ja, ich weiß halt nicht, wie es bei euch war, aber bei uns wurde 2002 der Strom abgedreht, weil – mitten in der Saison, weil wir die Rechnung für die Stadtwerke nicht bezahlt haben. Da ist sich der FC St. Pauli auch sehr ähnlich. Also das ist schon ziemlich krass gewesen, wo wir dann leider waren, obwohl wir halt schon vor der Gründung der Bundesliga eine krasse Hausnummer waren in Fußballdeutschland und dann halt irgendwann in den 70ern, 80ern verschwunden von der Bildfläche, aber irgendwie wieder zurückgekämpft mit jetzt dem neuen Stadion. Also das ist schon – wir kommen schon so ein bisschen aus den Ruinen und deswegen ja, wie gesagt, wissen wir, wo wir herkommen. Und der Jan ist eigentlich auch ein Verein für Fußballromantik, weil man setzt sich zwar nicht mit ihm auseinander, aber ich meine, wir sind, ich glaube, der einzige Verein in Europa, der einen Investor abgewehrt hat. Also und darüber gibt es so gut wie keine Geschichten. Und das war eigentlich ein krasser Wirtschaftskrimi.
Ja, kannst du das nochmal kurz in zwei, drei Minuten zusammenfassen, weil bei mir klingelt es da auch nur noch ganz leise, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, genau. Also bei uns gab es ja einen Spenden-Skandal von einem Immobilieninvestor und der Immobilieninvestor hat halt auch immer öfters Geld in den Jahren damals, in den Anfang der Jahrtausender gepumpt und hatte 30 Prozent von der KG quasi, von der Jan KG. Und der war dann beleidigt auf allen und jeden, weil er angeklagt wurde wegen Korruption, hatte aber nichts mit dem Jan zu tun, sondern halt mit der Stadt, also konkret um irgendwelche Grundstücksvergaben und hat dann einfach wie ein trotziges Kind seine 30 Prozent der Anteile an einen Philipp Schober verkauft, den kein Mensch kannte. Und dann war der auf einmal Anteilseigner vom Jan und die Ultras haben sich dagegen gestellt, der Aufsichtsrat hat sich dagegen gestellt, teilweise so, dass wir eigentlich ihm die Anteile überschreiben hätten müssen und wir sind nicht zu den Gerichtsterminen oder Notarterminen gekommen. Solche Geschichten. Und dann hat er die Lust verloren und der Jan hat die Anteile zurück gekauft. Jetzt können sie wieder uns.
Sie ist ja härter. Ihr hättet einfach nicht zu den Terminen erscheinen müssen mit Windvorost und Triple Seven und so weiter.
Also, ich mein, ein Investor will ja auch Rendite haben und wenn der merkt, der Widerstand ist zu groß, dann hat er halt keinen Bock mehr sein Geld zu verbrennen. Und dann hat er es, ich weiß aber nicht, für wie viel zurückgekauft. Der Mantel des Stillschweigens über diese Geschichte. Aber, ich meine, das ist ja trotzdem Fußballromantik pur. Ja, und wir durften, wir haben unseren Stadionnamen zurückgekauft. Das hat auch überhaupt gar keine Wellen geschlagen. Wenn das irgendjemand anders machen würde, wird es irgendwo Titelseite sein. Also, paar Sachen sind schon geil bei uns.
Woran glaubst du liegt das?
Ja, wir haben im Discord tatsächlich auch diskutiert und viele sagen halt, ja weil wir halt in diesen Klo reichen auf – also wir haben Discord-Channel für unseren Podcast. Genau. Und da haben wir diskutiert und ja, wir wissen es auch nicht so recht. Natürlich wahrscheinlich, weil wir eben zwischen den klo reichen Zeiten – 70er, 80er, 90er Jahren – von der Bildfläche verschwunden sind, so ein bisschen. Und weil wir halt noch nichts Außergewöhnliches geleistet haben, außer in die 2. Liga aufzusteigen. Aber wir sind halt noch nicht irgendwie ins Halbfinale der FW-Pokal gekommen oder haben mal die Bayern rausgeschmissen. So was brauchst du halt, glaube ich, um dann doch national bekannt zu werden.
Oder eine Relegation mit Bratpfannen kann ich auch empfehlen.
Ja, aber da sagst du es wieder. Ja, ich meine, bei der Relegation gegen 60 haben die 60er die Allianz Arena zerstört und sind dann rausgeschmissen worden.
Da habe ich gestern noch drüber nachgedacht. Ohne Witz. Wie hieß denn nochmal, wer stand denn da im Tor, der so total ruhig geblieben ist, als die Stangen geflogen sind bei Regensburg?
Philipp Pentke, der jetzt bei Hoffenheim in der Champions League gespielt hat, oder?
Das weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr. Philipp Pentke. Gestern habe ich mich mit jemanden drüber unterhalten und da habe ich noch drüber gesprochen, wie irre das war, dass eben damals diese ganzen Plastikstangen geflogen sind und Sitzschalen auch. Der ist halt einfach so Richtung Strafraumkante gegangen und der Schiedsrichter hat ja dann irgendwann dieses Spiel einfach weiterlaufen lassen, weil er wollte, dass dieses Spiel vorbeigeht. Ich glaube, er hat sich einfach darauf verlassen. Philipp Pentke wird schon von nichts getroffen und er bleibt jetzt cool, weil er war die ganze Zeit so, naja, was soll da schon passieren? Ein bisschen Plastik.
Er hat ja auch gemeint, er hat im Osten Fußball spielen angefangen, da gab es viel schlimmere Spiele oder so.
Stimmt, genau, der war wirklich total ruhig. Aber jetzt, um nochmal ganz kurz in die Gegenwart dann zurückzukommen, abschließend, also aktuell ein Punkt Vorsprung auf die Abstiegsplätze. Logischerweise ist damit aber noch bei Weitem nicht alles entschieden. Man spielt gegen alle Teams, die aktuell noch hinter einem stehen bzw. hinter die Letzten platzierten. Gegen die spielt man noch. Also in Sandhausen, die aktuell 18. sind, in Rostock, die aktuell 17. sind, auch nacheinander, das wird Ende April, Anfang Mai der Fall sein, und am vorletzten Spieltag in Braunschweig, die aktuell Tabellen 16. sind. Wir wissen jetzt natürlich nicht, ob das auch noch in der Konstellation dann so sein wird, aber alle aktuell direkten Konkurrenten auswärts. Wie blickst du auf euer Restprogramm?
Ja, mit gemischten Gefühlen, weil irgendwie ist natürlich irgendwie am besten, wenn man gegen irgendwelche Leute spielt, die halt, oder gegen Mannschaften spielt, die jetzt nichts mehr zu gewinnen oder verlieren haben am Ende der Saison. Aber dass wir es noch selber in der Hand haben, glaube ich, ist schon ein Vorteil, vor allem jetzt, wo wir wieder so ein bisschen psychisch auf der Höhe sind. Es darf halt nichts passieren bei uns, es darf singen nicht kaputt gehen, es darf OVUSO nicht kaputt gehen und keiner aus der Viererkette darf ausfallen. Das ist halt genau meine Sorge, egal gegen wen es dann geht. Also am besten eben verletzungsfrei und dann glaube ich nicht, dass wir absteigen, weil die Spielanlage mit der Stammelf zu gut ist. Und ich hoffe, dass wir spätestens in Sandhausen so in Anführungsstrichen klar machen mit einem Sieg. Da gibt es auch einen Sonderzug, der zweite Sonderzug in unserer Geschichte, der jetzt hundertprozentig stattfindet, weil die 500 Plätze verkauft sind. Sehr gut. Genau, wir haben einen Hypetrain und Respekt an die Ultras, dass sie es organisiert bekommen haben, weil ein Haufen Arbeit, so ein Sonderzug. Und ich hoffe, dass wir dann in Sandhausen quasi das zu einem Heinspiel machen und dann gewinnen. Und dass es dann dann so ein bisschen um ist. Aber das ist natürlich ein Traum. Aber wenn es am Ende mit der Relegation irgendwie klappt und wir drin bleiben, unterschreibe ich es auch. Hauptsache noch mal ein Jahr 2. Liga mindestens.
Da wäre ja vielleicht auch bei all diesen Kaderumstrukturierungen jetzt auch recht hilfreich, wenn man eben so viele auslaufende Verträge hat, dass man dann wenigstens verlängern könnte oder andere Spieler holen, die dann in die 2. Liga wollen und nicht in die 3.
Früher habe ich immer gesagt, quasi der Aufstieg in die 2. Liga ist ein Jahr Nicht-Abstieg, 3. Liga und DFB-Bokal-Qualifikation. So sehe ich es jetzt auch so ein bisschen. Wenn wir das nächste Jahr wieder schaffen, sind wir wieder ein Jahr und ein Schritt weiter. Wieder 2-3 Millionen Euro mehr fürs Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. So bodenständig würde ich das jetzt versuchen zu sehen.
Und wie es genau wird, das wird ja dann Tobias Werner in 1889 FM dann erzählen. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf dein Interview. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Das hat großen Spaß gemacht. Zwischendurch hat Tim mich noch geschockt mit der Fake News, dass Julian Nagelsmann entlassen ist. Aber offenbar gibt es einen Artikel, den ich jetzt nacharbeiten muss. Ich habe das alles nicht mitbekommen. Aber solange Selim Begovic bei Jan Regensburg bleibt, dann wissen wir, entweder es gibt niemanden, der ihn feuern kann oder die Welt ist noch in Ordnung. Und mit Frank Schmidt muss ich jetzt ja gar nicht anfangen. Das ist ja sowieso die Konstante des Profifußballs. Vielleicht schaffe ich auch irgendwann nochmal, mein Interview mit ihm zu bekommen. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Ich danke Petra Neher, der Adfrau-Näher auf Twitter. Schreibt ihr dort – und das ist jetzt der erste Zweitliga Kurzpass, wo du nicht noch die Heidenheimer Perspektive ausführlich im Vor- und Nachliefer musst. Nee, danke dir, dass du hier warst, Petra. Und herzlichen Dank an Tim Ecksteen vom Millantoon. Den kennt ihr natürlich alle unter tim-ecksteen. Kann man ihnen auch auf Twitter folgen. Danke dir, lieber Tim, dass du hier warst und mich sogar über die 1. Bundesliga auf dem Laufenden gehalten hast.
Der reale und nicht nur der Hypetrain, sondern auch der reale Sonderzug des FC St. Pauli fährt dieses Jahr übrigens nach Heidenheim.
Einfach was?
Normalerweise ist es immer am letzten Spieler oder zum letzten Auswärtsspieler, aber das ist jetzt dieses Jahr nun mal nach Kiel. Da wurde dann entschieden, über das ein bisschen kurz, um den Partywagon im Sonderzug hochleben zu lassen. Deswegen fährt er jetzt nach Heidenheim. Ja, er ist schon an vielen anderen Standorten angekommen. Ich kann da vom Innenleben berichtet man immer nicht, aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr, sehr schöne Angelegenheit.
Wir werden es beobachten. Das ist dann am 8. April das Topspiel Heidenheim gegen St. Pauli. Das haben wir ja vorhin schon angesprochen. Und herzlichen Dank auch an Robert Fischer, der uns mal hier eben schön durch die komplette Geschichte diesen Jahren durchgeführt hat. Danke, Robert, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst. Ja, jederzeit gerne. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das war's mit diesem Kurzpass. Gebt uns gerne Feedback, wie er euch gefallen hat. Auch dieses neue Format ist ja vielleicht auch gerade in der Länderspielpause dann gar nicht so schlecht. Es ist ein bisschen zeitloser zu halten. Ihr könnt den Rasenfunk unterstützen auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club erfahrt ihr wie. Und ihr könnt hier im Kurzpass natürlich auch noch andere Folgen hören. Wir haben über den letzten Frauen-Bundesliga-Spieltag gesprochen. Wir werden auch über den nächsten Frauen-Bundesliga-Spieltag sprechen. Und in der Schlusskonferenz geht es natürlich mit der Männer-Bundesliga weiter. Und die europäischen Top-Ligen haben wir auch noch, das dann wieder im Kurzpass. Und Tribüngespräche gibt es auch. Also euch wird nicht langweilig werden, auch jetzt in der Pause. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, bleibt gesund. Bis bald, hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.